and slowly from one from research South
America and my presentation is
historical information on one firm
language and Wolfram Alpha I tried to
explain some of the historical content
and functions on both systems everybody
I'm going to make a presentation about
the historical information we currently
now have in the world foreign language
and Wolfram Alpha
I was the developer that did the Ries
most recent update of these packets
mainly it includes the historical
countries and military conflicts this is
a bit of a new IRA offer the Wolfram
language trying to include the
historical information that until
recently we had only sketch for the
historical countries mainly have indeed
we try to overhaul it by adding polygons
and other interesting information
the idea is to to make computational
history to it is of making complex
calculations with historical data of
learning about history in a way that is
didactic using maps charts it's a far
better way to learn about history not
reading it in a book or attending a
lecture it's far more visual and we can
use the functions that are already in
the water from language to exemplify
this and show better this this data it
of talking about this I better start
with an example I choose the second
Punic War I don't know I like it
but it's a good example it's an
important war a world war of its era it
it pitted of the time the carnage and
the Roman Republic we can see here what
we can look about if we search this in
alpha basically were present previously
and here we have a map of the battles
all these basic information that we can
give about the war the participants it
includes more than the Romans and the
Carthaginians the time Lane the
commander for each fraction we can see
that the commanders are also included by
the nation this is a bit more
interesting because it's something we
can do calculations the casualties and
forces present in each and we can be
look here at a summary of the battles in
the war a bit of a distribution graphic
on the in further into the military
killed prisoners of war and such things
we try to be as specific as we could
with the data we had now what we can do
with geographical and they do related
calculations that are more interesting
for example to better understand the
conflict it's better to understand the
context in which it happened for
instance we can call upon the map of the
world at the start and the end of the
conflict we can see here the major
powers a Huey the colors don't help much
but it's much about this if you can see
this in the room we usually think of and
this is the Carthaginians this were the
two power great power
at the at the start of the war at the
end of the war in marks the start of the
wait that's what the that was a start
I wonder why Carthage was so little
Carthage which originally was all these
ended like this we can see it further if
we can do more calculations about this
first we can speak about the principal
factor in this word the Roman Republic
we can do calculations to see how much
it growth this is the maximum extent we
had on the Roman Republic we have maps
for each year for all historical
countries in the years since 2000 BC it
till today here we have the Roman
Republic until at its maximum extent in
the years 29 to 20 C BC 37 BC we can use
the nearest function to determine
because the map can be a bit tricky what
country current country it approximates
more by area in this case we can hear
that
jadon were the most similar countries in
area today Roman Republic at its maximum
extent you can give us a a better
understanding of how big it was or how
not so big it was we can use also the
more functions to do further
calculations such as the people that
were born in the in the Roman Republic
we can do this using the birth date and
birthplace but by getting the birth date
I can get the polygons of that of that
date and we can do a deal with in q2 to
get the entities that are located within
the polygon of the Roman Republic these
calculations have it complete
but we try to we are trying to make a
better better interface for this we can
also call up I told you about at the
beginning the property main actors to
call upon all the battles that were
fought by the Roman the way the Roman
Republic and put it on the timely you
can see here that this is basically the
most belligerent era of the Roman
Republic and marks the expansion of that
nation we can see it if the student of
history for example sees this is much a
better way to understand history and
simply telling you about it
we can also see how Rome evolved this is
a bit small I used here one of the
latest developed functions stuck
dateless plot to show the Roman Republic
Roman Empire here the Empire dissolved
partition into the Western Roman Empire
and the Byzantine Empire the eastern we
can see at the beginning the both of
them or were the size of the Roman
Empire basically this was the the
greatest extent here we can see if you
know the history of the Romans this is
the third century crisis and this is the
end
this was a strange period where their
Latin Empire existed because there
wasn't the Crusaders for some reason in
Beit
the the polygons we have also allow us
to make better calculations with the
areas for instance we can see here in
the second Punic War the two main
participants Carthage and the Roman
Republic how the areas of both countries
evolved in time here marked the
beginning and ending of the war we can
see that for instance even though the
Roman Republic didn't gain much
territory in the war it keep it kept
much the same and in the war it faced a
large expansion basically because it was
the laugh that's the only power as the
Macedonians and the Carthaginians were
soundly defeated Carthage you can see
started from here and then it here we
can see that well the Roman Republic at
the beginning of the war was 24% of the
area it would gain as a republic and 6%
agency at the considering all the Roman
civilization Kingdom Republic and Empire
in a curious way the Roman Republic at
the start who are the hurry at the start
of the war was the size of it Nam sorry
I better rush this we can do these
calculations to see for it for instance
that at the beginning of the war
Carthage was roughly the size of Iraq or
Morocco at the end the size of the
Netherlands we can see it here the
comparing size of these two countries
that were equivalently the areas of this
the nation the beginning and ending
I can release we can see an animation of
how both countries evolved during the
war you can see here first the
advancement of the Carthaginians and
then the response of the Romans and
their final victory okay here for
instance we can look upon the battles oh
great
[Music]
tentative values that's weird well they
we can mark the battle and the year and
call upon the polygons of that of that
of that year as well as the day this is
an interesting graphic who have the
accumulated casualties in the years of
the war what we do here is for each year
count the amount of battles were before
and sum all the casualties in each side
we can see here that they begin in the
Romans were hit heavily but at the end
the Roman casualties stabilized
while the Carthaginians go more on a
exponential almost in the summary of the
battles we can look for instance look
upon the but with more forces in them
the Battle of cannae or usually is a
greatest battle in the war we can see
here I live within romans and
carthaginians this is a total sum of
military forces because as we can see in
the next slide than I am extremely
rushing we can see for instance how the
forces work compound between infantry
and cavalry
we can see here for instance that even
though for instance in the Battle of
cannae the Romans had the advantage over
the Carthaginian the garage nearest 1/8
just the opposite
this time the Koreans had the advantage
but they lost but the cavalry proved
decisive in both battles they might have
least forces but the cavalry was
superior and if you know the Battle of
an IED you know that was one of the
decisive things have about that further
than the genius of Honeywell that we can
call upon here for instance we can see
all the battles the Honeywell was
involved in here is his timeline and the
past was he participated from the
scissors are going to Walter they find
our wars we can see here his for
instance the paddles he faced there is
the Roman forces he pays and the
Carthaginian for the he had the outcome
of the battle and the odds he faced we
can see here that he usually was in the
faced odds the odds were usually against
him and he won he will see his
counterpart his Roman counterpart in zip
and Scipio africanus the battles he
participated what's the same analysis as
with anyone and we can do a look up to
see when these these two generals meet
basically the wars and one is one battle
it's curious the two greatest generals
in the war only met
once now well this this is basically the
outline we can give with with a historic
with a second Punic War but there are a
few things I couldn't explain with that
war because of the nature of the work
for instance this graph examines the sub
conflicts the hierarchy between
conflicts in the Pacific War I couldn't
do this with the Second Punic War
because the the darius is no accepted
division of campaigns or anything like
that but in the pacific war we can see
this because the pacific war here at the
center the mayan campaign New Guinea air
campaign and all the battles here also
on a strange note we can for instance
select this is more a curiosity and than
anything the battles that were fought
are they elected a in a same ironic
fashion day like today is the Battle of
summon we can also analyze what battles
were poured near this location make a
timeline see the apparent conflicts we
can see that most of them were of the
Black Hawk War plopped them in a map
separated by colors by the apparent
conflicts
well the that is basically in a rough
way they think we have the things we
have here are the things we are now
currently working on we we plan to have
a as you can as you could see there is a
property that is outcome but is string
we are now parting it to give you a
number that says what fraction one out
the conflict we can do use this to bed
to make more calculations like for
instance this Honeywell the values he
fought and in which one did he won did
we do by checking what fraction did he
belong to and check it against the
winner fraction we can use a one a pie
chart to determine how was his rate of
victories we can do the same for African
O's in the second Punic War we can
analyze and give you map of the Roman
and Carthaginian victories the green
ones are the ones that were stalemate or
indecisive in some or our way you can
use also this geo bubble chart for
instance to this in this case the
bubbles are the size of the total
casualties of the of each battle and the
colors represent the victories of each
faction we can see here how because the
number of battles isn't as important as
how costly there were
[Music]
a timeline of the victories and well we
plan to have a more a better look up for
the for these historical things the air
we had a meeting about this recently
that take into account they date in the
Geo entities I we need to have like like
a deal with the people born in the Roman
Republic
for instance what Kant what nations for
instance if I plan to ask what nations
in a fifteenth century were located in
the territories of the former Roman
Empire this is something I currently we
currently can do but with such as this
or take a day to like for instance our
building and that it tells me in what
nation was constructed Thank You iris
finally these are the properties we are
now adding two historical countries this
regrettably we don't have much data on
population because it would be great to
okay to have more about this and compare
it with the areas and the capitals
[Applause]